-Performing "Blackest in the
Room" and "Feel no Pain"
from his album
"$oul $old $eparately,"
with a little help from
Anderson .Paak and The Roots,
please welcome, Freddie Gibbs!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Song begins ]
-Yeah. Uh.
Baby. Uh.
Gary Indiana. Uh.
Shout out to The Roots.
Yeah.
[ Rapping ] Where would you go?
What would you do?
Who would you screw?
Black Forces so his brain
ain't leave a stain on my shoe.
Uh. This GOAT talk,
bet they put my face
on that mountain, too.
Blackest in the room like I'm
Sam Cooke at the Fontainebleau.
Blackest in the room like
I'm Sam Cooke at the Copa.
East Gary playa, we fit together
like dope and soda.
Put that there on Nation.
My cliquelation
on Costra Nostra.
If I smoked him on this
side will I see him
when I cross over? Damn.
Gotta spit it
'cause it sit on my heart.
It's what I think when
I look up at the stars.
I went to jail,
the warden put me in the hole
'cause I wouldn't
rap for the guards.
I had bars back when Lambo
burned my demo on a CDR.
This GOAT talk, playa, TB12.
From the streets to the cell.
You know I bail, all well.
Got the AK with the catcher.
We ain't leavin' no shells.
Plus I'm surgical with this
thing like Training Day Denzel.
Yeah.
Blackest in the room.
Fred Hampton,
they came and shot it up.
Blackest in the room
Jeff Fort when he
hit Gaddafi up.
Blackest in the room.
Why can't playas hit
Clarence Thomas up?
My cousin live in Flint,
she been sick since they
messed the water up. Uh.
Yeah.
-♪ Let us pray ♪
♪ Chief conqueror, good author ♪
-♪ Promise we good forever ♪
♪ However it happens ♪
♪ I feel no pain ♪
-Gimme the bridge, tho!
♪ -Chief counselor, co-founder ♪
♪ My paperwork in order ♪
♪ However it happens, ♪
♪ I feel no pain ♪
-Gimme the bridge, tho!
- [ Rapping ] It's heavy
but I carry it with ease.
Juices and the berries
with a tail like Hakeem.
Breakin' down beef 'til
it turn to mince meat
and I'm with a mob.
-With a mob.
-Order bolognese.
Nice with the paws,
bob then I weave.
Now we at large
whippin' cars in the streets
like Keanu Reeves
when he just did speed.
Bust it down for me
and it better not stink.
♪ King conqueror, good author, ♪
♪ promise we good forever ♪
♪ However it happens,
I feel no pain ♪
-Gimmie the bridge, tho!
♪ -Chief counselor, co-founder,
my paperwork in order ♪
♪ However it happens,
I feel no pain ♪
-Gimmie the bridge, tho!
[ Rapping ] It's heavy
but I carry it with ease.
Like a high school janitor,
I'm carryin' them keys.
Gave out credit for
my dope I'm cashin'
paychecks with my fiends.
Back in the gap
when I hit that crack.
I served my sacks
at Mickey D'S.
On my mama 'nem
these crackers racist.
Noose at the races
Bubba Wallace them.
F a vacation I just want
justice for Breonna 'nem.
Can't go outside, I just might
catch Corona or a hollow tip.
In my fanta, wrist on Niagara,
got a lot of drip.
-♪ King conqueror, good author ♪
♪ Promise we good forever ♪
♪ However it happens,
I feel no pain ♪
-Gimmie the bridge, tho!
♪ Chief counselor, co-founder,
my paperwork in order ♪
♪ However it happens,
I feel no pain ♪
-Gimmie the bridge, tho!
-New York!
Freddie Gibbs!
[ Cheers and applause ]